[Musik]
es ist einer der größten
Anti-Terror-Einsätze in der Geschichte
der Bundesrepublik rund 3000
Polizeikräfte durchsuchen im
Morgengrauen Häuser Wohnungen und Büros
von sogenannten reichsbürgern in 11
Bundesländern nehmen 25 Verdächtige fest
darunter den mutmaßlichen redelsführer
einer terroristischen Vereinigung
Heinrich prinzreuß aus Hessen und die
Berliner Richterin Birgit mal sagt
Winkelmann die zuvor für die AFD im
Bundestag saß
und damit guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum ZDF Spezial sie wollten
den Bundestag stürmen Politiker
festnehmen Unruhen auslösen und so die
demokratische Ordnung stürzen es klingt
wie ein düsterer politischer
endzeit-roman aber geht es nach jenen
die bei den heutigen Razzien verhaftet
worden sind sollte er bald möglichst in
die Tat umgesetzt werden der
Staatsstreich der Umsturz der die
Demokratie in Deutschland beseitigt was
sind das für Leute die BKA und
Generalbundesanwalt dem Reichsbürger
Milieu zuschreiben wie gefährlich sind
sie wirklich und womit lassen Sie sich
aufhalten besprechen wir alles gleich
mit dem Präsidenten des
bundesverfassungsschutzes zuvor aber ein
Blick nach Niedersachsen in einen
Brennpunkt der reichsbürgerszene
fast 40 Jahre lang arbeitet er im Dienst
der Polizei heute morgen wird Michael F
aus Niedersachsen verhaftet weil er
zusammen mit anderen einen gewaltsamen
Umsturz in Deutschland geplant haben
soll
vor gut zwei Jahren tritt der 59-Jährige
erstmals bei Querdenker die muss auf
behauptet es gäbe keine Demokratie
bezeichnet seine Kollegen die Polizisten
als bezahlte Söldner und radikalisiert
sich immer mehr und ich bitte euch mal
darüber nachzudenken ob das vielleicht
auch in diesem Land einen Sinn macht
dass ihr euch zusammenschließt und sagt
wir gehen auf die Straße und wir gehen
erst wieder weg wenn ihr das gleich
passiert wenn hier eine Macht übernommen
hat die das ganze Drama und Schauspiel
beendet der Schutzmann mit Herz und Hirn
wie er sich selbst nennt wird vom Dienst
suspendiert vor sechs Monaten bestätigt
das Verwaltungsgericht in Hannover die
Entscheidung der Polizei Direktion
Michael F sei den reichsbürgernah und
als Polizist nicht mehr tragbar
Reichsbürger hängen
Verschwörungstheorien nach und lehnen
den deutschen Staat ab so erkennen Sie
die Bundesrepublik Deutschland nicht an
Reichsbürger berufen sich auf die
Grenzen des Deutschen Reiches viele von
ihnen sehen zudem den Staat als
Unternehmen
sie weigern sich das Grundgesetz
anzuerkennen und fertigen sich eigene
Pässe und Ausweise an teilweise weigern
sich Reichsbürger Steuern zu zahlen und
sie drucken sich eigenes Geld
im Milieu von reichsbürgern
selbstverwaltern und souveränisten dass
ich beobachte ist es so dass die
Ideologie grundsätzlich rechtsextreme
Elemente beinhaltet und antisemitische
und die antisemitischen überwiegender
deutlich da sind es dann die gierigen
Banker oder das Finanzkapital die Wall
Street oder die Ostküste was alles dann
Codes immer sind für eigentlich das
Judentum
2021 schätzt der Verfassungsschutz die
Anhängerschaft der Reichsbürger auf etwa
21.000 ihnen werden mehr als 1000
extremistische Straftaten zugeordnet
darunter 184 Gewaltdelikte zu den
reichsbürgern zählen Querdenker
Esoteriker oder einfach nur
leichtgläubige Menschen einige jedoch
sind radikal dieser Mann gilt als Kopf
der Umstürzler Heinrich der Achte Prinz
Reus sollte die neue Regierung als
Staatsoberhaupt anführen zudem steht er
im Verdacht den Komplott teilweise
finanziert zu haben
und in Berlin begrüße ich den
Präsidenten des Bundesamtes für
Verfassungsschutz guten Abend erhalten
wann guten Abend also Razzien in elf
Bundesländern dazu in Österreich und
Italien wie sehr haben die heutigen
Verhaftungen den militanten Teil der
reichsbürgerbewegung geschwächt ja das
war schon ein starker Schlag gegen diese
militante Gruppe der Reichsbürger und
Selbstverwalter Bewegung wir zählen in
Deutschland
21.000 Anhänger die diesen Ideen
nachhängen
viele sind durchaus gewaltorientiert das
sehen wir daran dass es auch mehr als
1000 Straftaten im vergangenen Jahr aus
dieser Gruppe gab diese Gruppe die heute
ausgeschaltet wurde zeichnete sich aus
durch eine sehr weite Vernetzung über
das gesamte Bundesgebiet durch sehr
präzise Planungen was man vor hatte und
die Vorhaben waren tatsächlich sehr
gewaltorientiert man hatte auch die
Tötung von Personen durchaus vor Augen
insofern ein wichtiger Schlag gegen
diese gewaltorientierte Gruppe und ich
denke mal das wird auch für alle anderen
ein abschreckendes Beispiel sein ein
Schlag mit 3000 Polizeibeamten heute
morgen im Einsatz dazu eine
außergewöhnlich hohe Zahl an
Spezialkräften mit wie viel Widerstand
auf Seiten der Verhafteten hatten sie
gerechnet und wie groß war er dann
tatsächlich ja wir wissen dass diese
Szene durchaus eben sehr
gewaltorientiert sein kann sie ist sehr
waffenaffin das heißt viele Reichsbürger
besitzen legale oder illegale Waffen und
auch wenn es uns gelungen ist in den
vergangenen Jahren mehr als tausend
legale Waffen einzuziehen so wissen wir
dass es immer noch genügend Waffen gibt
gerade auch in dieser Gruppe die heute
betroffen war war zu vermuten dass es
eben auch eine ganze Reihe
illegaler vielleicht auch Bundeswehr
Beständen stammende Waffen geben könnte
und es gab hier in der Vergangenheit
durchaus Beispiele dafür dass ich solche
Gruppierungen eben den exklusivmaßnahmen
der Behörden auch mit Gewalt widersetzt
haben wir erinnern uns an die tödlichen
Schüsse 2016 in Bayern aber auch in
diesem Jahr hat ein Reichsbürger eben
bei exklusivmaßnahmen der Polizei auf
mehrere polizeibeamt geschossen insofern
war tatsächlich äußerste Vorsicht
geboten zumal eben auch einige der
Verhafteten ja aus der Bundeswehr kamen
aus Spezialeinheiten der Bundeswehr kam
und insofern über entsprechende
Fähigkeiten
entsprechend gut ist es doch heute
gelaufen kein Polizist wurde verletzte
laut Bundesanwaltschaft hatten die
Verdächtigen ja ihren umsturzplan im
Grundzügen schon ausgearbeitet wie nah
stand Deutschland der nach ihren
Erkenntnissen vor einem
rechtsextremistischen Staatsstreich bzw
dessen versucht nun die
Verfassungsschutzbehörden von Bund und
Ländern unter der Führung des Bundesamts
wir sind dieser Gruppierung schon sehr
früh auf die Schliche gekommen wir
beobachten diese Gruppe jetzt seit
unter diesen Jahres und wir hatten doch
einen recht klaren Überblick über die
Planungen und die Entwicklung dieser
Gruppe und insofern haben wir
mitverfolgen können dass tatsächlich die
Planung immer konkreter wurden dass man
eben auch schon Waffen beschafft das ist
genaue Listen gab wer welche Funktionen
nun wahrnehmen sollte und zu dem
Zeitpunkt als wir annehmen mussten jetzt
kann es tatsächlich gefährlich werden
haben wir natürlich auch unmittelbar mit
Generalbundesanwalt und die
Polizeibehörden zusammengearbeitet
insofern würde ich sagen deutsche
Sicherheitsbehörden insgesamt hat die
Situation jederzeit unter Kontrolle aber
wenn es nach dieser Gruppe gegangen wäre
dann war diese Gefahr schon recht real
das sind interessante Details zu den
Razzien heute im Morgengrauen gegen die
reichsbürgerbewegung Informationen von
Verfassungsschutzpräsident Thomas
Haldenwang danke nach Berlin vielen Dank
ja bundesinnenministerin Phaser hat ja
gesagt die Ermittlungen ließen so
wörtlich in den Abgrund einer
terroristischen Bedrohung blicken wagen
wir einen tieferen Blick in diesen
Abgrund gemeinsam mit dem Psychologen
und Kenner der reichsbürgerszene
Sebastian Bartoschek guten Abend nach
Herne
guten Abend
gegen eine Bewegung die in den letzten
Jahren erheblichen Zulauf bekommen hat
wie ist die Anziehungskraft der
Reichsbürger zu erklären
ja die reichsbürgerbewegung hat immer
die
Unzufriedenen um sich geschadet
diejenigen die das Gefühl für sich
hatten abgehängt zu sein die den Staat
nicht mehr verstehen konnten und den
letzten Jahren haben wir natürlich durch
diese außergewöhnliche
Belastungssituation von Corona den
corona-schutzmaßnahmen den Umstand
gehabt dass viele Menschen sich
unzufrieden fühlten Angst hatten und
irgendein Ventil suchten um zu sagen
nein so kann das nicht sein ja und die
sind dann mitunter eben auch über die
einschlägigen querdenkerdemos ein
Reichsbürger geraten du musst mal sicher
unterscheiden zwischen den unzufriedenen
wie sie sagen die ja sich mit den
reichsbürgern sympathisieren und solchen
die aber auch bereit sind für ihre
Überzeugung zu den Waffen zu greifen und
von denen heute offenbar doch einige
verhaftet worden sind wie schmal ist
dieser gerade zwischen Mitläufern und
militanten in dieser Szene
ich glaube gar nicht dass es wirklich
ein Grad im Sinne des Wortes ist sondern
dass die Grenzen verwischen wir haben
gehört 21.000 Menschen sind diesen
Milieu zuzuordnen wir müssen uns klar
machen das sind alles Menschen die die
demokratische Grundordnung ablehnen und
wenn die sich dann selbst radikalisieren
oder über sie ihre Netzwerke sich
radikalisieren dann ist der Schritt hin
zu Widerstand was immer das abstrakt
heißt hinzu konkreten Widerstand mit der
Waffe in der Hand nicht weit auf die
meisten von uns wirken aber die Ideen
der Reichsbürger ja so verrückt dass man
sie bisher eigentlich als harmlose
Spinner abgetan hat was sagen sie als
Psychologe lassen sich Reichsbürger
überhaupt eines besseren belehren sind
sie Argumenten zugänglich oder Hälfte
allein die harte Hand des Gesetzes am
Ende
ich finde wir müssen da unterscheiden
wir haben auf der einen Seite diejenigen
die frisch für diese Ideen sage ich mal
begeistert sind oder zugänglich sind da
können wir tatsächlich etwas tun wir
können Sie mit Fakten konfrontieren wir
können Ihnen aber auch vor allem das
Gefühl geben du bist Teil unserer
Gesellschaft wir wollen dich bei uns
haben und dann haben sie diejenigen die
tief drin sind und ja dann muss ich
tatsächlich nach vielen Jahren bis zu
einem Jahrzehnt Beschäftigung mit der
Szene sagen da hilft nur und endlich die
harte Hand der Demokratie was wäre
schlussendlich ihr Rat an Politik und
Gesellschaft auch die Strafverfolgung
die justize wie lässt sich denn dieses
Szene so in Schach halten dass sie für
Demokratie für Rechtsstaatlichkeit keine
ernsthafte Gefahr mehr darstellt
also ich glaube wir müssen zum einen
endlich Umdenken wir dürfen den Leuten
die Demokratie Feindlichkeit vertreten
kein Rahmen geben wir müssen Leute wie
die Neonazis in der AFD
definieren wir dürfen ihn nicht mehr die
gleichberechtigten Foren geben zu
demokratischen Parteien wir müssen uns
dann die reichsbürgerszene genauer
anschauen wir müssen dort einen Fuß
reinbekommen und eine wichtige wenn auch
triviale Erkenntnis ist wir müssen die
Polizei besser ausstatten wir brauchen
da mehr Personal und wir brauchen vor
allem bessere Technik die
reichsbürgerszene ist eine die zu einem
großen Teil über soziale Medien oder
Messengerdienste funktioniert und da
muss man sagen da darf die Polizei da
dürfen die Staatsanwaltschaften nicht
schlechter gestellt sein als eben die
Reichsbürger
der Appell des Psychologen und
reichsbürgerexperten Sebastian
bartuschek danke für Ihre Auskünfte ihre
Expertise nach Herne
ja und auch das sehr geehrt ja der
heutige Tag diejenigen die an
verschwörungsmythen glauben und sie
weiter verbreiten sind eben keine
verschwindend kleine Randgruppe mehr es
sind Menschen die man in der Mitte der
Gesellschaft verortet und die mutmaßlich
zu Allem entschlossen sind entschlossen
vor allem die verfassungsmäßige Ordnung
zu beseitigen und auch wenn dieser
Erkenntnis erstmal Angst macht sie ist
doch vor allem ein Auftrag nämlich zu
schützen was uns oft als
selbstverständlich erscheint die
Demokratie in diesem Land
das war unser zdf-spezial danke für Ihr
Interesse und noch einen schönen Abend
auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]